hello everyone and welcome to
broadcast exploring the genetically
solid tumors using whole genome copy
number analysis presented by dr.
Ravindra Cole hey and dr. Joanna shovel
I'm Christie jewel of lab rats and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminars brought
to you by lab roads and sponsored by
thermo Fisher Scientific for more
information on our sponsor please click
on the thermo Fisher Scientific logo on
the left of your screen
now let's get started I want to remind
everyone that today's event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found on the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by using the ask a question box
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
I would now like to introduce you to our
speakers dr. Joanna Schiphol senior
research scientist at Stanford
University also speaking dr. Ravindra
Kohei associate professor pathology
associate director residency program and
medical director cytogenetics laboratory
a UMC for complete biographies on our
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the top of the screen
dr. scribble you may now begin your
presentation
you
hello everyone thank you for
participating in this webinar today I
will tell you about the use of snip
arrays for studying genomic profiles of
tumors with complex DNA copy number
alterations caused by Omaha comma
leiomyosarcoma is one of the most common
types of subtly sarcoma tumors arising
from different types of connective
tissues it's a malignant type of tumor
with smooth much muscle differentiation
the most common locations of my my
sarcoma include retroperitoneum
extremities and the uterus
leiomyosarcomas are associated with poor
clinical outcome and current therapeutic
options provide unsatisfactory results
also the assessment of response to
treatment in lay my circle my patients
is difficult since the conventional
imaging may not provide informative
results because of that new tools for an
improved evaluation of response to
treatment is highly needed for patients
with leiomyosarcoma
leiomyosarcoma tumors are characterized
by high genomic instability on the
picture on the left you can see an
example of a normal karyotype of a male
with two copies of each autosomal
chromosomes and one copy of each sex
chromosomes x and y on the round the
right hand side you can see a karyotype
of a representative case of
leiomyosarcoma tumor from from a female
and in this image you can see additional
copies of multiple chromosomes and two
losses of selected chromosomes the most
frequent DNA copy number losses in
leiomyosarcoma affect multiple tumor
suppressor genes like p53 RB 1 p10 aprx
or cdkn2a on the other hand the most
frequent copy number gains result in
amplification of my OCD gene that
encodes myocardium a muscle specific
transcriptional activator this graph
summarizes the median number of somatic
point mutations and copy number
alterations across different types of
cancers and based on this graph you can
see that you turn leiomyosarcomas as
well as why am I so comets arising in
different types of soft tissues are
characterized by intermediate levels of
both DNA copy number alterations and
somatic point mutations
the most important challenges in the
treatment of patients with Lyme a
sarcoma are related to the lack of
therapeutic targets in these tumors and
also inadequate method for evaluation of
response to treatment in this
presentation I would like to tell you
about our liquid biopsy studies in Lima
sarcomas based on profiling molecular
alterations in tumor derived DNA in
circulation
liquid biopsy approach may be
potentially useful especially for an
improved and non-invasive assessment of
response to treatment in patients with
sarcoma
potential applications of circulating
tumor DNA includes screening and early
detection of cancer and improve
diagnosis through genotyping of
circulating tumor DNA potential
applications include also detection of
minimal residual disease after the
surgery evaluation of response to driven
therapy and detection of genetic
alterations that may be associated with
resistance to certain types of
treatments and finally circulating tumor
DNA profiling may be also useful for a
long-term follow-up in cancer patients
to the to detect disease recurrence
circulating tumor DNA is found in plasma
or serum fraction of the black it
released by cells dying through
apoptosis or necrosis or it can be also
actively secreted in exosomes it has
been shown that DNA in circulation may
Harbor the same molecular alterations as
DNA in the tumor these alterations
include point mutations copy number
alterations chromosomal rearrangements
and DNA methylation the clinical utility
of circulating tumor DNA monitoring has
been shown in tumors that herb or highly
records mutation as I have shown you
Lima takoma represent the type of tumor
with a wide spectrum an intermediate
spectrum of point mutations and copy
number alteration therefore we proposed
a new strategy for providing of
circulating tumor DNA in leiomyosarcoma
patients and that approach combines
detection of point mutations by deep
targeted sequencing using a custom
capture panel together with detection of
copy number alterations through shallow
whole genome sequencing we assumed that
such combination approach may allow for
an increased sensitivity of detection of
circulating tumor DNA and may allow to
track a higher number of markers in
plasma
or detection of DNA copy number
alterations we profiles DNA extracted
from tumor specimens using unco scan FFP
ESI and we profile DNA from plasma by
shallow whole genome sequencing from
each patient we provide up to seven
different tumor specimens and several
longitudinal plasma specimen an
essential step in this process is
selection of appropriate FFP tumor
specimens first we evaluate the
percentage of tumor cells in the
specimen based on H&E staining for this
particular study we selected mostly the
samples with 90 to 95 percent of tumor
cells next we performed microdissection
of the espía tumor specimens by taking
several two millimeter cores from the
area with high content of tumor cells
after that we extracted DNA from this 2
millimeter chord using operative DNA RNA
FFPE kit including RNA treatment DNA
concentration and yield was evaluated by
qubit specifically we used the high
sensitivity double-stranded DNA si and
later we submit at least 80 nano grams
of DNA extracted this way for uncut can
FFP I say to thermal Fisher services the
first step in the analysis of the uncle
cam data includes evaluation of a
variety of quality control metrics
selected important QC metrics include
the median absolute pairwise difference
ma PD which should be below point free
and also snip quality control of normal
deployed markers which should be above
26 deploy 3 centering may be performed
manually if needed which may be the case
especially in the tumors with high
genomic instability I will show an
example of deployed with entering in the
following slide in order to identify
copy number alterations in our
leiomyosarcoma study we defined copy
number gains and losses as the regions
with lock to ratio above point 25 and
below minus point 25 respectively we
require the minimum of 200 probes per
segment to focus only on
relatively large alterations and with
this criteria we identify the medium a
median of 80 alterations per tumor
sample the plate reefs entering may be
required in tumors with high genomic
instability that may have low count of
diploid regions in such cases normal
deployed regions of block 2 ratio equals
0 may not be recognized properly by the
software and it may be necessary to
manually assign the deployed region of
the sample or in other words to recenter
the sample correct deployed regions may
be identified based on the B allele
frequency profile
in this example of Lima sarcoma tumor
specimen you can see multiple multiple
false positive code for example gains of
chromosomes 1 3 P or 4 P that are
represented in the top panel with log
two ratios we call these gains false
positives because they have no
corresponding allelic imbalance which
can be seen in the bottom panel called
above the allele frequency
to manually recenter the sample we may
provide an offset that tells the
algorithm how much the profile should be
pushed up or down so that the normal
deployed regions reside a dr. ratio of
zero in this case we indicate that
chromosome 1 is in the normal diploid
state we use the median locked ratio of
chromosome 1 which originally was 0.6 T
2 as the new dr. ratio 0 and in the
bottom panel you can see how the dr.
ratio of each chromosome has been
corrected after diploid centering using
chromosome 1 as the new deployed
reference
in this slide you can see genomic
profiles of the sample before and after
this correction the upper panel shows
the original profile was false positive
codes with corresponding without
corresponding allelic imbalances and in
the bottom panel you can see the profile
would correctly assigned normal diploid
region
based on applying deploy tree centering
and the analysis criteria that I
described in the previous slide we
identified the following abnormalities
abnormalities in our leiomyosarcoma
tumor specimens the most frequent
alterations included lots of rb1 tumor
suppressor gene and amplification of
myocardium gene which is an agreement
with the previously described align my
circle map profiles in the literature
interestingly in the study we provides
multiple tumor specimens from the same
patients or multiple regions of the same
tumor in order to study inter and intra
tumor heterogeneity of copy number
alterations in leiomyosarcoma in
patients lms - for example you can see
that we profiled two regions of primary
uterine I'm a sarcoma which is indicated
as t1 and t3 and we also profile a
metastatic tumor from brain and based on
genomic profiles of these samples you
can see heterogeneity within the primary
tumor which is indicated by a selected
copy number gains or losses that are
being present only in certain region of
the primary tumor and not in the other
for example in chromosome one or two in
patient lms five we profile the
metastatic retroperitoneal tumor and
multiple concurrent metastatic tumors
from the abdomen that were removed
approximately one year after the first
tumor specimen and in this example you
can appreciate also the inter tumor
heterogeneity in Lima sarcoma for
example by looking at alterations in
chromosomes 1 3 or 18 across different
tumor specimens in patients lms 6 we
profiled 2 different to different
regions of a primary pelvic
leiomyosarcoma
and to separate metastatic lung nodules
and from this profiles you can see a big
difference between genomic aberrations
found in two separate metastatic lung
nodules that are indicated as T 3 and T
4
and inpatient LMS 7 you can also see in
30 more heterogeneity based on the
analysis of the primary tumor from the
calve and metastatic tumor from the
thigh
after characterizing genomic profiles of
Zulia my circle my tumor specimens we
ain't identified tumor derived
alterations in cell-free DNA patient
matched plasma specimens on koshkin FFP
as i was used to define DNA copy number
profiles of lima sarcoma tumors because
snip arrays are currently the gold
standard for detection and
quantification of DNA copy number
alterations shallow whole genome
sequencing was applied to detect DNA
copy number alterations in plasma cell
free DNA but this method may produce
many false positive codes
therefore in order to identify only
tumor derived alterations in plasma DNA
we selected only the overlapping genomic
regions altered both in plasma and tumor
DNA in each patient
um shallow whole genome sequencing was
performed on selfie DNA extracted from
27 plasma specimens with the median
coverage of point 21x this allowed to
identify tumor derived alterations in
44% of the samples in five of seven
patients included in this study using
this approach we detected up to 194
tumor derived DNA copy number
alterations per plasma sample a copy
number profiling in circulating tumor
DNA was complemented by a targeted deep
sequencing by Coptic cancer personalized
profiling by deep sequencing using this
method we are able to track somatic
point mutations in tumor suppressor
genes such as p53 RB 1 and a TRX we
detected mutations in these genes in 68%
of the analyzed samples from six out of
seven patients included in this study
in this slide summarizes the creating
two more DNA profiles in selected
patients with longitudinal plasma
samples analyzed the green line
indicates circulating tumor DNA detected
by cap stick so deep targeted sequencing
the dark blue line represents
circulating tumor DNA levels detected by
shallow whole genome sequencing so DNA
copy number alteration and the light
blue panels in the background indicate
the duration of chemotherapy in patient
lms free you can see that initially high
levels of circulating tumor DNA become
undetectable after the initiation of
chemotherapy and radiation therapy
however circulating tumor DNA becomes
detectable again with the progression of
the disease a similar scenario was
observed in patient LMS five were
circulating tumor DNA levels dropped
after the surgery radiation therapy and
ablation but then the levels increased
throughout the progression of disease in
patient LMS 7 you can see that
circulating tumor DNA became
undetectable for at least one year after
complete resection of the tumor in this
profiles you can see that the levels of
circulating tumor DNA correspond with
the treatment in in those patients
finally I would like to show how
circulating tumor DNA may reflect inter
tumor heterogeneity a major advantage of
circulating tumor DNA compared to tissue
biopsies is that circulating tumor DNA
analysis simultaneously integrate
contributions from multiple tumor
deposits enabling a more comprehensive
analysis of tumor heterogeneity in the
left panel you can see that the one to
gain was detected by snip array only in
the same single tumor and it was removed
during the second surgery in the right
panel you can see that the levels of DNA
with 1q gain in circulation were
detected two different time points among
five hundred to denote plasma samples in
this profile we can see that the one to
gain was detected already in the first
plasma sample that was collected seven
days before the first surgery but this
DNA alteration was not detected in the
tumor sample removed at that time
because we analyzed only a single tumor
as a single region of the tumor
in summary our study of limas vakama
shows that Uncas can FFP essays are
useful for detection of DNA copy number
alterations in archival tumor specimens
I showed an example of deployed deployed
Rhys entering the dialogue for
correction of genomic profiles in tumour
in tumors with high complexity such as I
might say coma
our results showed that copy number
profiling using Uncas can FFPE essays
may reveal enshrine in their tumor
heterogeneity and in this particular
study genomic profiles characterized by
snip array in tumor specimens served as
the reference for detection of
circulating tumor DNA in plasma thank
you very much for listening and I'm
going to pass it over to dr. Cole
Thank You Joanna good morning my mother
Linda Cola I massage at Medical College
of Georgia Augusta University and today
I'm going to talk about the utility of
Smith arrays and targeted somatic
mutations and evaluation of histological
mimics of myeloma
these are relevant disclosures about the
talk I'm employed by Medical College of
Georgia and I do have support comes from
a shine to be additional disclosures
related to the talk but most importantly
as opinions expressed in this
presentations are my first though and
does not represent the opinions of
chemistry scientific and its affiliates
or any of my collaborations and
employers the product Aquos an activity
I'm going to talk about is intended for
molecular biology application and not
for diagnosis or prevention or treatment
as I mentioned earlier I'm a molecular
pathologist and a practice can decide
the genetics along with that in the
capacity as a medical director in the
CLIA lab director but I also practice
breast and surgical pathology and that
plays a critical role in using these new
technologies in evaluation of surgical
pathology cases this is my outline I'll
go briefly over the icy and slippery as
a whole but I think Joanna the normal
job in introduction to conquer scan I
want to focus on why we ended up
choosing melanoma as a poster child for
its utility you know and some other
histological challenging piece
Oh Anna
so four billion we only to acknowledge
the great service karyotype has done for
us in the past thirty to thirty plus
years but along with that we also need
to recognize the limitations
karyotype has especially the low
diagnostic yield
longer than our time and especially the
low resolution and it's really difficult
these days to find these trained people
who could help us repair typing and as
it is a subjective method it's prone for
human errors the other couple of
challenges we see especially in specific
pathology field for karyotyping solid
tumors is sometimes we get these blinded
samples in the frozen room which yield
basically a normal karyotype along with
it there's all growth of Manu plastic
cells again giving an inconsistent
results on top of that if it's a
necrotic tissue or an abscess which
leads to a culture failure or microwave
I provide growth in in karyotype
cultures
so I want to add a couple of points
Joanna's introductions that the office
can make proofs which we use for the
speak grade in the lab as a pre-nominal
coverage more focused on the ecology
targets under a docking were two and
45th nips but the icing on the cake
particularly especially who promoting an
ecology of the 74 snip probes for the
somatic mutation detection and these
probes are directed against 70
publications for nine critically
important genes in oncology like be
wrapped here as EGFR which are important
in either diagnosis prognosis of service
selection for majority of the cancer
there lastly the the need for my Korean
cancer research is critical because as
compared to other technologies we have
been using we don't mean the dividing
cells just the DNA from the target
neoplastic cells the assessment of the
genome is is extremely high-resolution
interesting purées interpretation is
objective and it's based on by
statistical algorithms so there is a
very less human bias well the great
advantage of using a separate is
detection of copy neutral stretch system
as I got that Europe LOH what we call
them and on the research side it's a
huge advantage because all the data is
digital then you could upload to genome
browsers and get annotated it and our
other annotated database and get really
nice infinitive information on and of
one piece
they're coming back to the discussion
topic of why we ended up choosing
melanoma as a poster child for the
snippet evaluation everyone knows that
melanoma is a critical problem specially
people in the south or in the Sunbelt
the 80s Danes issue still remains to me
an approach for a velvety melanocytic
torso in we're not trying to replace
heme with paper rays or any other
molecular testing the critical part is
not the diagnosis of melanoma but it it
is separation of these histologic mimics
of melanoma which are a very problematic
practical issue in the medical college
and then the reason for that is when
meldova
escapes early detection it is one of the
most aggressive and hide a different
form of cancers although melanoma is the
small the small part of the skin cancer
it is actually the major reason of skin
cancer related that in United States so
when I'm going to say about his logic
mimics of melanoma I'm talking about his
logic entities in the meta pathology
like a typical speciality with our
bindles of melanoma which mimic airbags
are attached by provisions we boil
melanomas proliferative nodules or large
in specially intended max engine idly by
clear cell sarcoma regress melanoma
versus telenosis melanoma transformation
specially in this plastic or atypical
universe so these are the kinds of
lesions which are histologically very
challenging in a small or limited biopsy
and then because of this limitation we
are aware that either melanoma is under
diagnosed or diagnosed and this base
diagnosis of metastatic lesion is at the
top of the list malpractice cases in
pathology specially in the Medical
College
so let's take a step back and look at
these progression of these melon
aesthetically Asians right from a mellow
site or dysplastic nevus there are four
main processes proliferation
immortalization invasion and metastasis
and and the good part is there are
critical changes both of the coffee
member as well as the snv's which are
gained added during these crosses which
are very specific for that particular
moment and people have been exploiting
these changes to use in different types
of assays to answer these questions of
melanoma versus histologically and one
of the first steps that introduced was
the fish testing to evaluate these cases
look at the first generation of the fish
acids which we use as a surrogate for
the genomic stability again this is the
data coming out from 10 to 15 years of
research on array CGH based on
non-static region all across the world
one of the challenge so one of the
challenge of these first-generation fish
asses was a very high cutoff for these
particular acid which makes it very
difficult to nominal especially in
critical T then the second generation of
the fish a where the new proofs were
added to expand the diagnostic utility
but still their cutoff for the lead was
cut off but these probes was very high
then and I said earlier that the
challenge was the sensitivity and
specificity along with cutoff for these
sets of full an added disadvantage was
polyploidy intra-party which was a
common source of false positives along
with these fish in these regions apart
from the limitations in the fish we felt
like melanoma had that multiple of the
reason between these two to look at one
was the TCGA data base I gave our four
new genomic subtypes of melanomas the
melanoma which had driven with b-raf the
one which had driven with grass nf1 and
triple wild type so I think at this day
and age we need to have general
information along with the histologic
diagnosis of melanoma with enable our
oncologist to identify cases in these
different group also if he does have a
pretty in-depth melanoma biomarker
reporting template which i think is
critical along with the type
so to summarize the reason we chose
melanoma because the ambiguous nature of
this is logic mimics is very problematic
limited the existing limitations of the
fish nesting the cap biomarker template
which needed more information and the
PCG provided the new molecular subtypes
to summarize via the different genomic
aberrations in different melanocytic
lesions which I captured across last 15
to 20 years of research and the idea was
whether we can put them together it
could help us use as new face technology
and and and help separate these his
logic mimics so you know initial
evaluation using Argos Ganapathy
actually what they did was we picked up
50 cases of melanoma which were worked
out in a reference lab on fish testing
out of fish 36 where his logically
mimics of melanoma which were proven on
fish and the 14 your fish proven
melanoma 95 of these pieces are puncher
shaped biopsies the small tissue to the
realist examples which we receive from
our drug clinic all the samples in our
study fast initially you see all the
samples were run on the office can the
assay and the data was analyzed on the
chance to pointable analysis software
provided by the manufacturer so in
reality we were looking in these 50
sheets of mal moment because I'm going
to show you another slide which dealt
with all these different examples of
analytical lesions and and their range
of complexity associated with melanoma
and how challenging they are in
preventing us from making it consensus
diagnosis of melanoma so these are some
examples of the cases in our study in
each and every one yeah for possesses a
challenge in making a diagnosis of
melanoma for the lab workflow of most if
not all the cases we get the block from
our histology or don't pad we look at
the hne slide a macro dissection is
perform the book depending on the theme
of similarity in the second flips and
the DNA is extracted
to use it on 5 micron sections from that
would be block to the three sections
depending on the size of the tissue
depersonalization DNA isolation the data
drop but you see a check and then
adjusting the Vienna volume to get well
Donna gram per microliter concentration
for the acid
so again to summarize the kinds of
samples or this logic diagnosis and
their numbers which in this evaluation
assay was anything which range for a
typical dermal spindle some elastic
collision to something as a compound
pigmented a typical special teamer
within genetic features that features of
believers of either bluey accomplished
histologic mimics of melanoma it should
be used in our evaluation as a district
you an example of how whole genome view
would look on our mascara at the answer
this isn't just an example of them
although my case which shows the gaining
loss and the critical genes which are
usually abnormal in the melanoma and as
I earlier mentioned advantage of an
armor scanner that Beyonce is that is a
probe against 74 negations and one of
them is a VIP xfinity which you can
identify indicated a kilogram
to the results of the evaluation study
was pretty nominal we were able to good
I get near 100% now equal sensitivity
and specificity but for me the most
critical value was the negative
predictive value so in the a save you're
not trying to make the diagnosis of
melanoma but will be trying to make sure
that we are not missing melanoma in
these histologic mimics of
so in addition to the domestic
assessment of these cases we use a
rhombus Ganapathy a safe for assessment
of low-grade about brain tumors it's a
pic Eliza mattes tumors a typical I
might assume is I think Lana did a
phenomenal job in explaining the
critical importance of sleep raised more
recently we have started to evaluate the
vines like brushing happen examples and
see how we can use office can SP in in
evaluating these sample types I'm just
going to go quick we uh put additional
surgical pathology pieces which we are
evaluating and helping or surgical
pathologist so well it could be very
example I think this is now a standard
of here in majority of the economic
collapses the low-grade little brain
tumors that are the biggest advantage of
using a NASA like office can empathise
is a combination of both series as well
as rotations the any GM article again
based on the TCGA database basically
identified the limitation of physiologic
diagnosis saying that the low-grade
gliomas if you have an ith wild type of
one p19 cube for the way should have a
whole different clinical presentation
and outcome irrespective of the grade
type and that has led us to identify
this new regeneration of testing
modalities to help our neuropathologist
and your oncologist so I'm just
summarizing the nega article which
basically
basically identifying this this
limitation in our Civic pathology
diagnosis so for the second example how
we evaluated the Augustine SSB assest
for low grade adult brain tumors we go
through a barrage of sleep areas
something as idh1 and to beat at 600
EGFR pdgfr medication one b19 clue
deletion and so on which has helped us
tremendously due to a proper evaluation
of our great
adult brain tumors and this is just
evidence base but weak we have the whole
algorithm which talks about self
pacifying the molecular classification
house adult brain tumors on snap arrays
special anonymous connected
this again a whole genome view of adult
brain tumors which looks at different
genes which have dysregulated on an
adult brain tumor which it again it is a
very critical in analysis for based on
new whu-oh classification of adult brain
tumors this is again a whole the Cara
Graham view which adds the ith one one P
19 Q an analysis to the surgical
pathology valuation of the Sala gated
poly goat dentro glioma case in addition
to now Noah and adult brain tumors we
also look at a typical ibanez here
especially differentiating between
something as simple as my phone versus
liposarcoma on the limited core biopsies
we have again look at garage of
abnormalities which are critical in
making that differentiation and this is
just an example which we presented at
the IEP meeting last year which looks at
these small core biopsies which are very
histologically challenging especially in
a big retroperitoneal region with the
whole genome slippery
definitely makes a substantial addition
to the histologic evaluation of these
small biopsies especially
differentiating between lipoma or
liposarcoma something raised to build on
the psychology like specimens very
trying to differentiated and reactive
music videos for cecilia ma with a loss
of the evap one which can be detected on
a minister chemistry but also on an LH
of BPM VAP one especially on three p21
one makes a huge addition to this
logic evaluation of these again
technologically challenging cases like
me to versus react and we do so if V to
the the additional cases or additional
surgical pathology scenarios where an
acid-like oncogenesis be your sniffle
rate and make a substantial addition to
the histological logic evaluation for
the surgical pathologist or
cytopathology 3 we use them for a
typical item at achievers real so
passing moment especially for his lodi
classification especially even via the
small core biopsies for post-cryo
surgeries we have ongoing research
project to understand the scene beanbags
esophagus Peschel ii in again in
psychology or smaller specimen GYN
oncology with synchronous primer is met
metastatic lesions as I earlier
mentioned we also looking at evaluating
this wiki in the Libyan fantatic back
brushings so this is a lab dr. Shelby
dr. mundo and dr. DuPont there are the
different people divided which makes all
these things possible and these are some
other Research Associates in the lab and
the lab techs working of this pretty
good project Thank You Christy
thank you dr. Cole he and dr. shovel for
that informative presentation
we will now start the live Q&A portion
of our webinar if you have a question
that you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for okay let's get started our
first question now dr. should go dr.
Cole hey I believe this could be for
either of you
how many snips are covered by the Onkel
scan FFPE essay
I can take question actually so the
uncle can FFPE sa captures alleles of
over 220,000 snips across human genome
and in addition they're around 900
countries that are covered with
increased density of probes for better
resolution
thank you now dr. Cole hey I believe
this one's for you
what is the DNA quality and quantity
required by the on cuffs can a Fae
in our evaluation studies and currently
in the lab we try to get as much as
possible but our minimum cutoff is 80
nano grams of total DNA with the 12
nanogram per microliter as input volume
and it is measured by qubit both
double-stranded and that that something
as that simple has been pretty
successful in our assay
thank you dr. Koh hey dr. shovel let's
come over to you on this one
how were the DNA copy alterations
identified in plasma cell free DNA
we apply the protocol that was initially
developed for non-invasive prenatal
testing by our colleagues from K level
in Belgium and in briefly performed
single and sequencing on Illumina
machine and we could really required at
least 10 million reads per sample to be
appropriately match and we identified
copy number alterations in plasma cell
free DNA using modified plasmatic
algorithm and what is important for this
analysis we used almost 400 profiles of
healthy donors to define what is that
base what are the baseline profiles in
healthy individuals and based on this
baseline we defined genome-wide
segmented discourse in samples from
leiomyosarcoma patients in relation to
those normal profiles so then that's how
the copy number alterations were called
based on the discourse calculated plasma
so Swee DNA
thank you and let's go ahead and have
you answer this one as well what type of
specimens do you typically use
the samples that we typically use for
specifically for uncle can except de si
are our sarcoma samples because this is
what our laboratory is focused on so
during my presentation I explained
exactly what is their process how we how
we select the samples we pay a lot of
attention to high content of tumor cells
that is first evaluated by pathologist
and then I think that also this type of
micro dissection of the sample is very
important to avoid contamination from
normal cells
thank you and doctor cold hey I'd like
to ask you the same question what type
of specimens do you typically use
the Christian in our evaluation study as
well as currently in the lab we use
[Music]
multiple different specimen types mostly
our FFP in the FFP we use samples coming
from punch biopsy resection specimens
excisional biopsy and as Joanna said
most if not all of these samples get a
teeny examination by a pathologist to
assess the tumor celerity and tumor
enrichment and then we do the macro
dissection for DNA isolation the samples
are coming from a variety of tumor types
like melanoma adult brain tumors lie my
Ma's my my sarcoma as anything any any
specific histologic subtypes where we
have a challenging case we tend to get
these samples more recently we have also
tried to evaluate the assay on
cytology specimens so these will be
fresh fna samples and at the end of the
day what matters is a good quality and
quantity of DNA if you can achieve that
I think the assay performs well
thank you and it looks like we have time
for one more question and dr. Cole hey
let's and on this final question why the
genomic region was analyzed in the
targeted deep sequencing of plasma DNA
I think I'm gonna let dr. Joe and I
answer that because I think her lab is
done the work of the plasma DNA do I
know you want to take this yes yes of
course so for for this study we we
designed the custom capture panel that
covers more than 180 Kb and this was
specific panel design based on the
analysis of 77 and I might psychometry
more specimens that were analyzed by
TCGA consortium we used exam sequencing
data from this specimen but with normal
DNA from those patients and that way we
identified more than 300 eggs on that
were the most frequently mutated in
those patients and that's how we came up
with our custom panel for deep targeted
sequencing of the most frequently
mutated regions in leiomyosarcoma
and that's what we used to profile cells
with DNA from plasma
thank you again doctor cold hands doctor
so bold do you have any final comments
for our audience
I would like to just summarize by
pointing out that on Kafka and FFP si is
very useful for detection of copy number
alterations in alcohol tumor specimens
and specifically it's also useful for
characterizing tumor heterogeneity in
tumors with high dynamic complexity
and then to follow up on Joanna's
comments I think Chrystia what donkus
Canada fiance has done in surgical
pathology is is helping our surgical
pathologists to you do a pretty decent
molecular analysis on his logically
challenging cases like the one I
mentioned in my talk but on top of that
it has also helping us to provide a
better diagnosis and prognosis of cases
like a dog brain tumors to match up with
the new classifications which are
focused on which are focused based on
molecular subtypes now before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration I'd like to
once again thank dr. Ravindra Cole hey
and dr. Joanna chable for their time
today and for their important research
we'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor a thermo Fisher Scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed on
the band and labret swil alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
until next time goodbye